I love what I'm doing right now it's
enjoying my life and I'm getting to do
things that I'm passionate about with
the people that I love Selena Gomez is
living her best life and blocking out
all of the haters as recent as this
weekend when social media trolls slammed
Madison beer after she was spotted with
Haley Bieber here's what happened on
Saturday Justin Bieber's past and
present collided at Hollywood hotspot
Craig's where his wife was photographed
hanging out with beer at the same time
his ex-girlfriend Selena was there
enjoying a night out with friends and
celebrating the release of her new album
rare soon after the run-in trolls
started targeting beer on Instagram
commenting with snake emojis and hateful
remarks but Gomez wasn't having it
I think it's nice to have a little bit
something to myself the singer quickly
clapped back writing this is disgusting
reading all of this and confirmed that
the run-in wasn't intentional she
continued quote I'm so disappointed that
people would speak to someone like this
I have known Madison since she was a
baby and watched her continue to become
the woman she is there is no issue
Gomez concluded her message I want
people to know that every every single
life is valuable that their voice can be
heard and other people who are willing
to be there for them Bieber took to
Instagram as well
sharing a message about how comparison
is the biggest killer of happiness quote
don't compare what you lack with what
others have because they also lack
something that you have instead
appreciate the blessings that we all
occupy but back to the reason Selena was
at Craigs in the first place
to celebrate her highly anticipated new
album of course I think that the whole
objective of the album is self-love and
acceptance the 27 year old singer
dropped rare on Friday and et caught up
with her at the Doolittle premiere where
she revealed why now is the perfect time
to release new music you may just wait
five years for rare it just didn't feel
right before I I wanted to make
something that was transparent yet
really classy and very real to me so I
just I guess this was the right time and
I felt it so that's crazy you know what
I'm feeling I'm feeling dance again come
on now makes me feel so good that song
makes me feel like I got my stuff back
and I feel like all right I'm back in
the game a bit
[Music]